[Music]
so last week we looked at a couple of
recent attempts to finally solve the
what is a woman riddle um as you may
remember they both failed in spectacular
fashion their answers didn't even make
it past square one they blew up on the
launch pad and killed everybody on board
metaphorically but at least they tried
because we've finally forced the left to
confront this question they realize they
cannot evade it any longer
they have to confront it and so all of
the best minds in the gender ideology
world have set to work this is like a
the manhattan project of green-haired
gender studies majors they're all on the
problem now they've been brainstorming
around the clock an all-star team of the
smartest and most insightful gender
activists in the world
all with comparatively impressive iqs
compared to the rest of them some
reaching even into the high double
digits and they've been digging into
this problem deliberating
searching desperately for a solution
and yet so far
a woman is anyone who identifies as a
woman is the best that any of them have
been able to do
it's as though the manhattan project
spent years on research and development
and rather than inventing the nuclear
bomb
they came up with like a firecracker
although at least a firecracker is an
actual thing it exists it makes sense
a woman is anyone who identifies as a
woman is nothing it's not a definition
it's not anything it's circular it's
incoherent and yet again it is the best
that they have been able to do
until now
here to meet the challenge or to die
trying is a writer called paul john
polls paul is a a self-identified
feminine trans man which i guess is a
female
who identifies as a male
and sees herself as feminine
that presents its own bundle of chords
to untangle but there's not time for
that today
it does mean though that the writer is
coming at this question from a from a
pretty unique perspective because
usually the gender ideologues who try to
tackle the woman question are males who
wish to find a definition of woman that
will include them
but in this case interestingly enough we
have a female who wishes to find a
definition of woman that does not
include her
how will she do it
well pjp begins by acknowledging a few
points that the gender ideologues
usually prefer to ignore she points out
that
gender cannot rest on stereotypes and
social constructs as her side usually
has it because that effectively excludes
a lot of people from womanhood that she
doesn't want to exclude
it also includes her
but she doesn't want to be included next
the writer recognizes that a woman is
anyone who identifies as woman is
circular and therefore logically invalid
she does acknowledge that she also
points to another problem that i hadn't
even thought about
with the you know a woman whose anyone
identifies as a woman definition she
says that that hinging the definition of
woman on self-identification
is a problem for her side because it
excludes people
who don't yet consciously identify as
women but may at some point in the
future you know the trans community
creepily refers to people who they think
might be trans or can be turned trans as
eggs that's what they call them eggs
right eggs that need to be hatched
and uh they may sort of uh home in on a
boy who they think could be made into a
girl a process that we used to call
grooming before every social media site
banned the term
but the point is that
they want to be able to say
that the boy is already a girl and has
always been a girl
yet hasn't realized it
that's what they want to say
so
when uh when when
the boy is nine years old and first says
i'm a girl
uh no it's the the trans side they don't
say well that he just became a girl then
they said oh he was always a girl even
before that
he just came to realize it now
well see that doesn't work if the very
definition of womanhood or girlhood
relies on conscious self-identification
that's another problem
so what can be done about this
here's the writer's solution
i'm going to read now
quote
this finally brings us to our definition
a woman is an adult human
whose subconscious sex
is female
the beauty of it is that it doesn't
include trans men or cis men their
subconscious sex is male and it includes
both cis women and trans women their
subconscious sex is female and it also
doesn't invalidate gender non-conforming
trans and cis people and the best thing
about it is that the person who is best
qualified to know whether or not you are
a woman is still you which means that we
can still keep our beloved ethical
guideline of respecting people's
self-identification except that now the
word woman actually means something
well no it doesn't in fact it's never
meant less if that's the definition now
i can appreciate that you've made a
valiant effort to avoid a circular
definition but unfortunately your
efforts have driven you even farther off
the logical path and deep into the woods
where it's dark and confusing and no
light penetrates through the canopy um
it's even worse now here's something we
haven't talked about in a while let me
ask you this
what if there was someone out there who
kept a log of every single thing you did
every minute of the day what have i told
you that's exactly what happens every
time you go online they're logging
everything logs all over the place your
internet providers like att or comcast
they're allowed to store logs of every
website you've ever visited and can
legally sell this data to anyone that's
why i always use expressvpn expressvpn
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure servers so your
internet provider can't see or log what
you do online now many of you might be
wondering
well if i'm routing all my data through
a vpn doesn't that mean that the vpn can
see what i'm doing and log my data
instead ah very insightful you're right
to think that but many vpns in fact do
claim to have a no logs policy but
they've been caught logging customer
activity anyway
expressvpn is different that's why
they're the only vpn i trust because
they use trusted server technology this
makes it impossible for their vpn
servers to store any data including logs
of any expressvpn customer and you don't
have to take my or expressvpn's word for
it expressvpn is so confident in their
no logs claim that they have had one of
the biggest assurance firms audit their
technology so stop letting people keep
logs of what you do online visit
expressvpn.com matt walsh show right now
and find out how you can get three
months free so let's review all the
problems with this definition number one
uh your your subconscious by definition
is the part of your mind that you don't
have access to you are unaware of it
actually the subconscious or unconscious
mind is a psychoanalytical theory
invented by freud
there are all kinds of logical and
scientific problems with it it also has
given risen to all manner of psychiatric
fads and panics such as the infamous
repressed memory hysteria back in the
90s when a whole bunch of women in
therapy all realized all of a sudden
that they had been abused as children
and then a whole bunch of people got
arrested based on that and it turned out
that they were like imagining it um
for that matter the concept of
transgenderism wouldn't exist either
without these freudian concepts of you
know the unconscious mind and so forth
so there are problems is what i'm saying
with the whole idea of the subconscious
at least as it has traditionally been
understood
but that takes us off on a tangent about
how the entire field of psychoanalysis
is built on nonsense fabrications and
wild theories invented by a bunch of
weirdos 100 years ago
we're going to leave that to the side
and stay focused
the point is that the term subconscious
means and this is what it means
the part of your mind you aren't aware
of
so if someone is subconsciously female
they wouldn't know that they're female
if you know that you're female then you
are consciously female not
subconsciously but of course saying a
woman is anyone who is consciously
female is just another way of saying
that a woman is anyone who identifies as
a woman you're trying to avoid the
endless logical loop which is why you've
introduced the subconscious into the
equation but you can't really do that
the subconscious cannot save you
in fact its entrance into the
conversation creates far more problems
for you than it solves
also your subconscious cannot have a sex
your consciousness also does not have a
sex in and of itself
by definition sex is a physical category
having to do with reproductive organs
and chromosomes and dna
you you are here positing a scenario
where a person with a physical sex of
male
could have a mind even an unconscious
mind
with the physical sex of female
so you have turned the mind into its own
physical entity
literally contained inside the physical
body and which has its own dna
this is what you're doing not to the
mind not to the brain but to the mind
essentially you're imagining the human
body as some sort of
fleshy shell with a whole other person
inside it steering it around that makes
for a good plot point in a science
fiction film but it's not how things
work in reality
in reality you can cut a person open and
inspect every part of them including
their brain external and internal and
all you will find are physical body
parts and every physical body part has
physical dna which will attest to the
physical sex of that person
and that's why your definition doesn't
work and makes no sense
and in the end is even less coherent
than the definition that you were trying
to avoid giving
that's really the problem isn't it
though
what you're trying to avoid that's the
issue
see it's it's it's very clear
has never been more clear
that the gender ideologues really what
they actually want to talk about is the
human soul
every day they move closer to the
precipice inching toward it step by step
they talk about self-identity and inner
awareness and gender identity and
subconscious sex now but what they mean
what they want to say
is that humans have a soul
and sometimes the soul doesn't match
with the body
they stop themselves from saying that
because they don't want to admit that
gender ideology is through and through a
religion it's a religious spiritual
claim it's a matter of faith
this is the secret they're trying to
keep hidden but they're coming closer
and closer to dropping the scientific
mask and admitting the truth that this
is this is religious this is what they
this is a religious claim they believe
in the soul
and when they say that a man is really a
woman
they mean that he is spiritually a woman
that his soul is that of a woman
that's what they mean
of course understood that way it still
is nonsense doesn't make any sense at
all you cannot talk about souls
without talking about god and he's the
one who makes the souls and the body
and it's absurd obviously to claim that
god would make some sort of mistake on
the spiritual assembly line and
accidentally plop a female soul into a
male body
that doesn't make any sense
i mean what sort of what sort of vision
of god are you now postulating
some sort of bumbling uh fool up there
in heaven that's just like
you know throwing different souls into
mismatching bodies has no idea what's
going on
besides this concept of souls is built
on a this concept the concept that the
gender ideologues have is built on this
weird kind of dualism where the soul is
seen as once again an entity located
inside the body and steering it along
like like the body is some sort of
two-legged suv but in reality our souls
and bodies exist in harmony with each
other
it's not that we are bodies and we have
souls or that we are souls and have
bodies we are souls and we are bodies
we cannot be one thing spiritually and
the opposite thing physically
that's a
contradiction
you might as well say that
you have the body of a human and the
soul of a raccoon or an oak tree it just
doesn't make any sense
so retreating into the spiritual realm
will not actually save gender theory it
actually makes it even more absurd than
it was when it was judged purely on a
scientific basis but at least
if we are talking about it spiritually
at least then
the conversation is being had in an
honest way
at least the gender ideologues would
finally be saying what they actually
mean
and that would be progress
though again it will not save them
or our friend paul john polls from being
today cancelled
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated